here now with a full report Fox News
White House correspondent Peter Ducey
but I don't think your question was
lousy at all I thought it was very good
question Peter I congratulate you
and Sean today it was a lousy question
almost four full years ago when I asked
him for the first time how many times
have you spoken to your son about his
overseas business dealings uh he
eventually got through his answer and he
told me to ask the right question and
tonight I'm wondering what is the right
question I heard from a White House
official just a few minutes after my
exchange with the president today here
in New Mexico who said they take issue
with the premise of my question they
said my question is wrong because I
referenced speakerphone conversations
with business associates about business
they say that question is wrong and that
the president's answer is right that
they never talked on speakerphone about
business
if that's true uh it's not proven uh but
that is what they are saying however
that is a big headline because they are
no longer saying that he did not have
these speakerphone conversations with
the associates period so it now seems
like there were conversations we don't
know exactly what they were about
they're pointing to these Devin Archer
uh transcripts with the house oversight
committee where he says they talked
about uh kind of just polite
pleasantries including the weather but
Devin Archer later went on to say in an
interview that it is categorically false
that Hunter did that Hunter and Joe did
not talk at the time about
business and so that's where we're at
today out here in New Mexico the
president moves on he wants to be
talking about uh green energy and not
anything in the past but I and I am
going to say something and this might be
dangerous with a studio audience because
they might not all like uh what I'm
about to say but
President Biden deserves a lot of credit
today because he actually called me over
to uh ask a question he has told me in
the past after some of our exchanges uh
that he doesn't mind a hard question and
so he knew it was going to be something
probably like this uh but he was guilty
because he once called you an SOB if I
remember correctly I think he feels
guilty yep you remember correctly yeah
but he he did stand patiently and he he
let me come up I had to hop a bike rack
to get to him uh but he stood there and
took the question so uh if you're
watching Mr President uh thanks
oh Peter Ducey thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else